all right I'm Laura Ingram and this is
the Ingram angle from San Francisco
tonight thanks for being with us
Shameless not blameless that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
now the trail of death along the border
is something that's become so
commonplace in our inability to prevent
the spillover into the United States
it's so overwhelming
that I worry that we've almost become
numb to it
it plays out like its own Twisted daily
drama we see all the stories
and it's where Hollywood depictions
aren't far off from reality
[Music]
hey welcome to
well things aren't just breaking bad
during the Biden years they're breaking
worse all because he refused to live up
to what he promised us all right Joseph
Robinette Biden Jr do solemnly swear
that I will Faithfully execute office of
President of the United States we're all
for the best of my ability preserve
protect and defend Constitution of the
United States
now what duties is he Faithfully
executing when he's allowed this to
happen
immigration attorney Simone nasiri says
San Diego's border is going to be seeing
a lot more of this says the end of title
42 is looming I think you're going to
see maybe close to 20 to 30 percent more
people come to the Border in the coming
weeks
just to take advantage of what's in
place
and what exactly is Biden preserving and
protecting and defending when his
refusal to secure our border leads to
the scourge of fentanyl pouring in from
Mexico my son was a casualty of this war
he was a 19 year old brilliant boy
stolen by Fentanyl
his name is Tucker Rowe more than 600
people a year have recently died from
accidental overdoses in San Francisco
the vast majority from fentanyl I'm
angry I'm heartbroken for the families
that have lost children they should have
got addressed a long time ago
three of El Chapo's Sons were just
indicted by the feds along with 25
others for running a massive fentanyl
smuggling operation as part of the
Cinderella cartel so my question tonight
is who voted for any of this now I don't
recall our hologram candidate in 2020
campaigning on his mission to create
absolute Anarchy at our Southern border
and remember it is poisoning our cities
with drugs and crime
from Baltimore where five individuals
were arrested for operating a fentanyl
drug trafficking operation to all the
way up in Auburn Maine where a whopping
three million dollars worth of the same
drug was intercepted after being shipped
in a package from Arizona to a local
restaurant
and where I am here in San Francisco the
fentanyl problem is so bad they're
calling in the California National Guard
we need to do everything we can to
provide all of the resources so that we
have the capacity to handle a problem of
this magnitude
yeah Democrats like mayor London breed
aren't pointing the finger at those to
blame in National leadership of course
not ditto with Chicago's Lori Lightfoot
now a few days ago she had the nerve to
try to blame the huge number of migrants
flowing into the windy city on the state
of Texas as in Governor Greg Abbott now
in this Brazen letter she wrote your
lack of consideration or coordination
and any attempt to cause chaos and score
political points has resulted in a
critical Tipping Point we simply have no
more shelters spaces or resources to
accommodate an increase of individuals
well of course if she were an honest
person which she is not her letter
should have been addressed to Biden
mayorkas and her own Senator Dick Durbin
instead she headed to CNN we are
completely tapped out we have no more
space no more resources I'm solely
compassionate to the fact that the
borders are themselves really overrun
but you don't solve that problem by
simply sticking people on buses to a
city that they didn't ask to come to for
an uncertain future and now where we are
literally full
wait wait you're literally full
so should Texas hold all the illegals
plus they're not full companies and
people are fleeing Chicago by the
thousands and that's because of her
terrible pro-criminal policies not Greg
Abbott
and speaking of brazen this gal's
burning up when it comes to Illegal
migration you've seen it come down by
more than 90 percent and that's because
of this act the actions that this
president has taken Republicans have
continued to use this as a political
stunt a political tool and not actually
come to the table to have a conversation
on how to protect dreamers if they want
to do political stunts as we've seen
from Governors and Mayors across the
country
now circling the Welcome Wagon for Lori
and Joe and the whole gang of course she
is
now she said it's down 60 what's down 90
optimism about our future among our
people
their policies produce the highest
influx of illegals in U.S history
the mass murder over the weekend of five
people including an eight-year-old boy
by an illegal alien Francisco oropesa
who's been deported by the way five
times between 2009 2016. it's just
another Stark reminder that illegal
immigration is not now and never has
been a victimless crime
orapesa is still on the Loose by the way
now Democrats not only have no remorse
for these deadly policies they don't
just try to turn the tables no they try
to change the subject
it's language that's the real threat to
America as in when Greg Abbott described
many of the victims as illegal
immigrants as well
the callousness the inhumanity of it all
really is breathtaking it's not
surprising coming from Governor Abbott
instead of the basic Humanity
he felt the need to label them
the humanity of it that compassionate
an open border is the most
uncompassionate thing you could do thank
you very much now in the regime media of
course they're always there for the
assist always the alleged suspect
Francisco oropeza there is some question
about a citizenship he supposedly had a
a I guess they referred to it as a a
consulate card from Mexico meaning he
was here legally but perhaps he had
overstayed so Chuck I I won't comment on
it because it is an active case
oh I bet he didn't want to comment on it
but every now and then Chuck Todd will
really shock you and actually ask a
decent question what's uh the definition
of secure border to you
it is in the context in which we are
working it is maximizing the resources
that we have available to us to deliver
the most effective results
well I've got to say an open border
after all is their goal so they wanted
an open border we got an open border so
to them their policies are effective
now I've been covering this illegal
immigration issue since I first started
in the media back in 1996 I was working
for CBS believe it or not back then
and that was when a Democrat president
actually did show that he cared somewhat
about this issue of the Border Bill
Clinton launched this thing called
operation gatekeeper and two years
earlier that's when it happened in 1994
and both parties back then at the time
saw the damage that illegal immigration
was doing to Southern California
the angle believes nothing has done more
to convince people in Middle America
that their so-called leaders are hostile
to them than this issue
so whenever we talk about the elites you
always know what's the elites or the
establishment whatever term you want to
use to describe the UNA party that
includes both Joe Biden and Liz Cheney
you're talking about people who believe
in open borders and that Alliance
includes virtually all the media and
throw big business in as well and by the
way none of them none of them care that
Americans overwhelmingly do not want
open borders and overwhelmingly they
blame the federal government for
creating this current mess
I know it's easy to get demoralized out
there and I get it but this is no time
for anyone to throw up their hands it's
time to vote and early or vote on
Election Day but vote you must
because these people in power they want
you to be demoralized as they sit idly
by why our country is being poisoned
they're not blameless they're Shameless
and it's time to deport them from
politics once and for all
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else